fusion entre alstom et si mince
l'objectif était de fabriquer de
constituer plutôt un géant européen dans
le matériel ferroviaire
sauf qu'il ya quelques heures la
commission européenne a dit niet niet
parce que à ses yeux ce serait un
obstacle au bon exercice de la
concurrence
alors tout le monde est à front renversé
dans ce dossier bruno le maire supposé
être pro européen lui est furieux il
était déjà ce matin sur france 2 le
ministre de l'économie
parce qu'en fait on savait bien que la
commission allait dire non écoutez le je
considère d'abord que c'est une erreur
économique et que les critères qui ont
été retenus par la commission européenne
n'étaient pas les bons la commission
européenne nous dit le marché européen
n'est pas ouvert au géant chinois
je crois exactement le contraire je
pense que d'ici très peu de temps nous
verrons arriver le géant chinois sérère
c'est en europe et puis je pense que
c'est une faute politique parce que le
rôle de la commission européenne
le rôle des institutions européennes
c'est de défendre les intérêts
économiques et industriels européens
alors pour ceux qui ne sont pas abonnés
la vie du rail crcc le géant mondial
le premier constructeur de trains au
monde c'est un chinois et il fait 26
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
et alors du côté des contents il ya
marine le pen la présidente du
rassemblement national eurosceptiques
déclaré qui pourtant applaudi à tout
rompre à la décision de la commission
je suis ravi et outré de voir avis que
le mariage ait pas lieu mais ravis que
le mariage n'est pas lieu c'était pas
d'ailleurs un mariage objectivement
c'était un don que nous faisions à
hacher mince de alstom qui est une très
grande industrie c'était un véritable
scandale parce que tout ça ça appartient
pas monsieur macron faut quand même
qu'ils se le dise à un moment donné et
pas plus que ça n'appartenez hier à
monsieur sarkozy ou un monsieur chirac
tout ça ça appartient en réalité aux
français or on ne cesse de départir les
français de leur propre possession de ce
qu'ils ont construit eux leurs parents
leurs grands parents leurs aïeux et tout
cela au détriment évidemment de notre
indépendance de notre puissance et de
notre souveraineté alors landiras ya
plein d'arguments la ya le côté la
souveraineté française même si alstom
n'est pas une entreprise publique donc a
priori les actionnaires en font ce
qu'ils veulent et puis il ya cette idée
que faire un géant européen ce serait
mauvais parce que ça ferait
monter le prix du matériel donc c'est le
consommateur qui en souffrirait c'est ça
la la politique presque l'idéologie de
la commission européenne on ne dit que
marine le pen s'était rapproché de sa
nièce avait abandonné des idées de
gauche de son ancien directeur de
cabinet philippe haut visiblement c'est
pas le cas parce que effectivement
alstom c'est le voeu que l sommes
appartiennent aux français mais il faut
nationaliser on a fait on a fait ça
d'ailleurs en 46 ans a fait 180 je ne me
souviens pas que le front national à
l'époque était pour les nationalisations
et ses 38 ans fils être de gauche alors
non ce que je
non mais je réagis c'est juste c'est ce
qu'a dit non je pense que nos amis de la
commission ont fait une très grave
erreur effectivement parce que ils se
sont dit on va protéger les les
transporteurs européens s'intéressent
ème siècle la bundesbahn et ses clientes
avec ailleurs alstom et siemens
il faut qu'on garde une concurrence très
bien mais ils ont ce qu'ils ont pas
compris effectivement c'est que ces gens
de la commission c'est qu'on vit dans un
monde mondialisé et que face aux géants
chinois ou face peut-être ajout si les
américains font des 30 c il faut avoir
un groupe européen regarder dans
l'aviation nous avons airbus il ya deux
groupes qui veulent nous tuer boeing qui
est aidée fortement par la justice
américaine qui veut vraiment tuer airbus
on parle est un autre jour si vous
voulez ou même maintenant et puis il ya
les chinois comac
voilà on a un peu peur que des chinois
aisés mais qu'un s'entendent sur notre
dos d'ailleurs pour avoir un duo paul
qui soit boeing comac et puis abuse donc
là je pense que à l'évidence il faut un
groupe européen alors je ne sais pas je
veux pas rentrer dans les détails de la
fusion dont parle
madame le pen mais il est évident qu'il
faut avoir un très grand groupe européen
pour pouvoir exporter en afrique en
amérique latine en asie en inde par
exemple pour apporter la concurrence et
indiens ou chinois
anne-lorraine bigeon avez vous envie de
défendre margrethe vestager requis et la
commissaire européenne à la concurrence
et qui a justifié dans un communiqué
aujourd'hui le refus de la commission de
d'entériner cette fusion en disant ça
entre est devenu hausse des prix et donc
ce serait pas bon pour le pour le
finalement en fin de compte pour le
client du chemin de fer alors la
défendre non je crois que la décision
les difficiles à comprendre elle arrive
à contretemps ressent tous le besoin de
renforcer l'union européenne aujourd'hui
y compris quand on est très pro
européens donc je crois que la
contradiction vous soulignez n'en est
pas une
si on est très pro européens ou comprend
qu'il faut que l'europe s'arme pour la
période à venir et que donc il faut
qu'elle se dote de champions industriels
mais cela dit je crois que la colle à la
commissaire à la concurrence si vous
voulez elle a fait ce que l'union
européenne sait faire et très bien faire
depuis maintenant et 10 20 30 ans elle a
défendu des règles de la concurrence qui
sont il est vrai tourner un peu toujours
vers le marché intérieur vers la
constitution d'un marché unique et qui
oublient parfois de regarder vers
l'extérieur et vers la concurrence on
l'a dit de la chine et des états unis
mais juste rappeler son la défendre
cette commissaire elle travaille sur un
édifice de règles et de droit qui sont
aussi ce que l'union européenne a su
faire presque de mieux ces dernières
années ça marche la politique de la
concurrence européenne et quand elle
s'en prend à d'autres monopole les
gaffes à pour ne pas les nommer
google amazon on est très contents
qu'elle décide d'empêcher la
constitution de monopoles ou qu'elle
recommande de les mettre au pas donc on
s'est quand même difficile de faire deux
poids deux mesures voilà alors c'est
intéressant c'est que les internautes
sont très partagés sur ce sujet vous
savez que d'un point de vue
les vrais arbitre c'est vous cher ami
qui nous regardent et sur lefigaro.fr
anti mac par exemple vous dit la
commission n'a fait qu'appliquer les
traités signés par la france
et il ajoute quand ce sont les pays de
l'est qui n'appliquent pas les traiter
on les traite de populiste alexis
lacroix écouter bien sûr c'est cet
auditeur et cet internaute n'a pas tort
c'est vrai que la politique de la règle
fait partie des politiques conduites par
l'union européenne
et c'est la spécialité de la commission
où les gens qui travaillent d'ailleurs
sont tout à fait compétent à limbé
stagaires ne manque pas de compétences
d'appliquer les règles mais quand même
si on a une vision un peu large des
enjeux européens
on sait aussi il ya un livre très
intéressant de l'ue 28 dollar qui est
paru là dessus que depuis une dizaine
d'années il ya aussi la tentative d'une
existence une auto affirmation politique
de l'europe pour s'émanciper
progressivement de la politique de la
règle et exister justement sur cette
scène mondiale très dangereuse avec des
acteurs qui sont nos concurrents exister
sur un plan politique
donc si on se cantonne quand on met en
europe à la politique de la règle on
n'existera pas il faut passer à quelque
chose qui soit une politique de la
décision de l'auto affirmation politique
est il d'ailleurs enfin bluwal me dollar
lui parle de une politique de
l'événement mais ça c'est qu'on peut
croiser cet aspect mais je le cite est
simplement comme illustration de
l'étroitesse de tir la commission et
puis par ailleurs moi je peux pas être
d'accord si vous voulez avec le fait
qu'on met en échec ce beau projet de
fusion pourquoi pas ce que vous voyez
vous voyez bien guillaume c'est
d'ailleurs une sorte de ballet de force
de formidables bas les masques
là vous voyez bien que ceux qui s'en
réjouissent c'est ce qu'ils ont toujours
voulu que l'europe n'existe pas comme
acteur sur la scène du monde dont au
premier chef naturellement marine le pen
met plein d'autres gens on ne peut pas
si je suis absolument d'accord avec
l'ami renault on ne peut pas se réjouir
de cette espèce de comment dire de deux
coups de poignard donnés dans la
nécessité aujourd'hui de créer des
acteurs économiques qui existent sur la
scène du monde en tant qu'europe et donc
le franco-allemand bien sûr moi je sais
très bien que le franco allemand il est
largement marquée par une hégémonie
économique de l'allemagne
est ce que c'est un problème où on y
gagne au change on aurait gagné au
change d'avoir lemay distance d'un album
sting on aurait gagné au change
ça voulait dire une france plus forte à
l'international la saveur
france plus faibles et comme par hasard
naturellement marie le pen applaudit
alors ce qui est quand même intéressant
c'est que y'a pas que marine le pen qui
est content il ya aussi des gens qui
sont a priori pro européens notamment
les syndicats les syndicats français qui
disent c'est très bien les syndicats
d'alstom qui disent mais aussi il était
contre cette fusion ce que vous avez un
point de vue sur ce sujet par écrit soit
en oublie alors moi ce qui me semblait
évident là c'est vraiment la cacophonie
et le chaos dans le camp des européens
c'est étonnant cette division à quelques
mois des élections
personnellement j'ai tendance à donner
raison à bruno le maire
c'est stupéfiant de voir qu'au fond il
ya plusieurs europe
dans le camp des européens et peut-être
que le débat ce sera une europe forte
économique et politique et une europe
libre échangiste kiki et qui va à contre
sens de cette europe forte voilà
l'analyste même si une europe libre
échangiste c'est aussi peut-être au
profit des consommateurs
du coup les théâtres les produits sont
moins chers à 100 il semble que ce qui
ce qui est ce qui apparaît c'est qu'il
ya un clivage entre une idéologie
européiste kiné qui ne défend pas
vraiment les intérêts de l'europe au
logis de la concurrence en tout cas mais
on peut la faire évoluer je crois que ça
montre vraiment la nécessité de la faire
évoluer si j'ai bien compris cette
affaire donne déjà lieu à des réflexions
en france en allemagne pour intégrer
dans les règles de concurrence non
seulement la défense du consommateur
mais aussi la défense des intérêts
stratégiques la défense de la
souveraineté européenne
on peut faire entre les règles il s'est
fait pour ta ça se construit c'est fait
pour évoluer
grosso modo historiquement ce qu'on a vu
au cours des dernières années c'est
qu'on a vu un très profond un homme très
profondément européen qui était
directeur de cabinet de dollars qui
s'appelle pascal lamy qui a fait rentrer
les chinois à l'om c'est et les chinois
n'ont respecté aucune des règles de l'om
si vous voulez
fondé une compagnie d'assurance ou une
banque en chine good life bonne chance
et et que est en revanche la commission
c'est mon pays hyper strict avec les
entreprises européennes
ça ne tient pas en géopolitique c'est
simplement ça ne tient pas et c'est
comme et la commission accepte de
manière béate l'extra territorialisation
du droit américain c'est-à-dire qu'on
10,9 milliards d'impôts à la vérité mais
moi j'aurais été le patron de la
commission le lendemain je l'avais payé
votre us je couvrais qu'il ya un
emballement de goldman sachs et je
convoquais le patron de nasser d'impôts
c'est des gens lui avaient dit et j'ai 2
milliards d'amande
c'est une amende voire le la banque a dû
payer au trésor américain ne pas avoir
respecté les voiles et le week-end alors
qu'elle avait respections à margaux les
lois européennes merci à claude sac 25
milliard de membres pour avoir aidé un
gouvernement européen maquiller ses
comptes publics c'est à dire c'est à
dire la grèce là les américains auraient
merci à l'évidence je rejoins
paul-françois on est d'accord en fait
vous avez à l'évidence deux visions vous
avez à l'évidence deux visions de
l'europe
alors je sais pas si c'est dans le camp
européiste mais c'est qu'au sein on va
dire des institutions européennes vous
avez la commission qui tend plutôt
l'interception libre échangiste qui à
mon avis là je vous donne mon avis
personnel on a un point de vue est une
conception passéiste
aujourd'hui dépassée au regard des
enjeux qu avec renault nous analysons
les enjeux internationaux et vous avez
une conception plus politique c'est
celle du conseil de l'europe du conseil
des ministres de l'europe
et là c'est vrai que pour l'instant les
cambrioleurs mais ce qu'on sait non mais
je finissais important tout ce qu'on
sait c'est que depuis 2007
vous avez des actions politiques d'un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques au niveau européen je pense à
sarkozy à son époque qui était beaucoup
dit fermé un jour on lui rendra justice
ils ont fait avancer l'europe politique
et donc c'est cette europe là qu'il faut
continuer parce qu'on a plus que jamais
besoin de fusion genre al seeb siemens a
à l'elysée at l'aurait me rends pour
nommer luc mais oui ça fait jamais de
regretter sarkozy je vous montre la vie
des idées des internautes qu'on a
questionné sur le figaro.fr hélas
approuvez-vous l'addition de la
commission et bien c'est un non franc et
massif sur 20
3000 voitures un peu plus ses 78 % de
nos puis je vous livre aussi en forme de
conclusion c'est commentaires de nos
internautes
nicole qui nous dit un petit peu comme
paul françois paoli en tout cas faire ça
à quelques semaines avant les élections
européennes bien joué point
d'exclamation c'est évidemment ironique
et elle en nous dit un beau projet de
fusion pour l'interrogation parlez-en
aux employés d'alstom effectivement on
faisait allusion à la réaction des
syndicats on va parler maintenant des
manuels macron c'est que dans les médias
on adore les sondages peut-être un peu
trop mais enfin celui là nous semble
quand même intéressant il est paru chez
nos confrères de paris match
ce matin c'est un sondage ifop fiducial
et voici la courbe de popularité ou plus
exactement de confiance dans l'action du
président de la république il gagne 6
points par rapport au mois dernier
emmanuel macron taquilla 34% des
français bon tiers qui approuvent
l'action du président il n'avait pas été
à des niveaux pareil depuis l'été
dernier
est ce que ça veut dire pour le françois
paoli que la la crise des gilets jaunes
finalement est derrière nous je suis pas
sûr que la crise des îles et jaune soit
derrière nous ça veut dire ce qu'on
savait déjà c'est que macron et quand
même quelqu'un de très de très fort sur
un plan sur un plan politique
ça veut dire aussi merci au gilet jaune
une certaine manière parce qu'en fait le
pourrissement des actions du gilet jaune
le fait que ce mouvement était
extrêmement bien perçu des français et
puis ensuite ça a dégringolé dans
l'opinion et finalement macro on a eu
l'impression qu'il avait qu'il a eu un
comportement d'homme d'état ses
responsables est assez raisonnable
ça lui a profité à plusieurs titres et
notamment pour ce grand débat donc oui
je pense que macro enfin une troisième
chose c'est évident que macron profitent
du vide d'une certaine manière politique
qu'il a en face d'eux en face de lui et
il apparaît comme l'homme raisonnable
il est d'ailleurs intéressant de voir
que c'est auprès des électeurs de droite
emmanuel macron progresse le plus dans
cette remontée dans les sondages alors
une bûche dans votre point de vue moi
j'en ferai une lecture beaucoup plus
prudente 1 je crois que cette crise
n'est pas du tout derrière nous et je
pense qu'il faut la active et peut-être
plusieurs échelles temporelles
à court terme le président apporte une
réponse politique les gens veulent être
entendus ils veulent être écoutés c'est
le grand débat l'organisation du grand
débat c'est sûr que politiquement c'est
fort mais au terme du grand débat qu'est
ce qui va se passer parce que la
dernière fois que emmanuel macron a fait
un exercice de ce type s'était la
campagne avant l'élection il ya eu cette
grande démarche de consultation des
français mais